what makes millionaires go insane
this man might have the answer youtuber
noelle miller
much more popular than me that's totally
not why i'm clickbaiting him in this
video
he just came out with a theory called
the millionaire anamorph theory which
i'm dying to talk about
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
10 million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and today
we're talking about science we're
talking about important theories
and we're talking more most importantly
perhaps
about millionaires flexing here's why
i'm talking about it okay
i feel like i'm sort of an england bus
driver like those uk
bus tour drivers with like and that's
the big bit that's the crazy thing over
there that's this
i do that with internet marketers online
i'm like hey look at what that
guy's doing hey look at what that idiot
is doing but i'm just kind of a man of
the
the people i don't have a great way of
like scientifically categorizing these
guys i just want as many people to gawk
and laugh at these people as i can
because i think it's funny i think it's
amusing i think these people are worth
calling out but
noelle miller comes in here like
uh copernicus and revolutionizes my idea
of how to think about millionaires let's
watch a little bit shall we so i went
down a rabbit hole of these
self-made millionaire guru personal
finance people
and i kind of have now in my mind this
sort of
anamorph evolution of the millionaire
first of all great science being done
right here but you see what i mean
like i look at these guys and i just
laugh i just think they're just uh
each one is their own unique special
psychopath their special snowflake
sociopath
he though he just starts out he sees
this world he immediately categorizes
and i love that i love that we're going
to talk about it because i think he gets
a ton right
i think there are a few things we could
add to it and uh let's see what you
think do you think the millionaire
anamorph hypothesis is correct we're
going to
talk about it i think it's pretty
interesting because a couple years ago
i feel the internet concept of a
millionaire were dudes like grant
cardone
and tai lopez you know guys with
maseratis ferraris and
big houses by the way i love the idea
that the internet's idea of a
millionaire is people flexing on you
um isn't that sad that that's our state
of affairs all the millionaires we know
are just people flexing their wealth but
his hypothesis is basically that
the money changes you slowly blah blah
blah and they have their own place
in the anamorph scale but there are
steps before that that i feel have only
been recently revealed to us
i find the first stage of millionaire is
the humble millionaire
the balding hasn't begun yet they have
these videos like i sold everything and
you know i only
work off of a piece of wood that i took
from a yard sale
yikes i'm getting some uh graham stefan
vibes here
this is the beginning stage of the
animals now i don't know if i agree with
this
i think there's another stage and i
think this might be the first place that
the peer review
and i think that's what we have to do
here listen all great scientific ideas
have to go through peer review why not
us to peer review this most glorious
of uh hypotheses so i think
that this first part is the most
incorrect of the entire thing
which is i think it's a great idea the
millionaire anamorph thing
i think it's actually the marketer
anamorph which is what's actually going
on
because there's tons of like pretty
normal millionaires who just never talk
about it but because of that you never
see them talking about it so they
they're never included in the theory
because you never see them i think what
you're actually seeing is
internet marketers have realized this
new grift of pretending to be rich and
then eventually you become rich
so the real first stage of the anamorph
in my opinion are children who have
realized that they need to pretend to be
rich
got a text there so something like this
might be the first stage
how i map 100k
per month at 16. this is sort of the
first step
right but basically the rest of this
theory i agree with but
as they continue to make more money and
they start to see that they have a
formula
that works then they evolve and they
become the
youtube pre-roll guy
[Laughter]
wait stop the humble millionaire
the pre-roll millionaire the space in
between
and then i'm actually a millionaire yeah
so i
only disagree with that agree with this
agree with this and this is really where
i think things get
really out of touch i mean you're really
you've lost the plot you think everybody
on earth can become millionaires
and you want them to spend their last
thousand dollars on you i don't know
what the number is
but somewhere you turn into this dan
pena
he apparently has made a trillion
dollars he calls himself the trillion
dollar man
and uh you know he's got a sales program
that teaches you how to make millions of
dollars
dan i feel represents that sort of off
the deep end rich
this is why you're [ __ ] poor okay
uh yeah i have to agree okay at some
point you go
off the deep end for sure but i think
the key distinction here that i want to
make in this theory
is that a lot of these people have
always been delusional and i don't think
it necessarily has to do with uh
making so much money as it does with
they want to stand out right
so like i said i want to tweak this
hypothesis to be the marketer anamorph
hypothesis
which is they start out they're innocent
they're like hey i want to make you you
know
a thousand bucks extra a month ten
thousand dollars then you become the
pre-roll guy
and eventually when you start making
real money at the top you realize the
more i can promise the more i can
position myself as like this amazing guy
the more money i'll make so in a world
with so much competition of these
millionaires yelling at you
you kind of find that to go to the top
you have to be the most outrageous the
most
insane the most pathological i mean
grant cardone talks about the fact that
he faked his own bankruptcy
for views the rumors of my bankruptcy
that is soon to happen yes it's true
okay i'm losing the plane the condo pick
it all up guys
this i think is the puzzle piece that
could maybe put our anamorph story
together why these guys seem to go kind
of psychotic
on their way to the top let's check it
out guys guys uh look
it's very very difficult to get any
attention right now
any attention at all because of what
wuhan
china virus coronavirus recession
contraction airline industry people
dying uh worldwide pandemics
it's hard nobody wants to listen to 10
acts how do you get attention how do you
get attention
in an environment that that is that
noisy
guess what you have to get real noisy
you got to have an imagination you got
to start thinking about crisis
if like faking your bankruptcy like that
kind of crisis uh because that's what
this guy did he kind of faked his
bankruptcy which is hilarious because
you know he's got like a whole grant
cardone capital whatever so he's got
like investors and he's like yeah i had
to
goof on you guys and make it seem like
you may have lost all your money oops
this is the way the marketing game plays
there it is folks
this is the way the marketing game plays
this is a shell of his former self let
me tell you that
look at his face i mean has he had
worked on cheese that is rough
this is cardona's worse honestly the
pandemic had really hit at this point
this is april i think he's doing better
now
but uh this was a tough time for him and
he decided to lay all his cards on the
table
you got to drop bad news to get anybody
to pay attention to you
i mean crazy news like it needs to
include like murders
uh bankruptcies failings
uh people getting hurt murders but i
can't believe how many of you out there
that know me have been in our offices
that are investors with me i can't
believe how many of you out there went
for it
you guys understand how insane this is
this like is like a guy
saying publicly you got like a a company
right you got people invested in you
you say publicly without warning you go
on instagram live and you go i'm going
bankrupt i'm going bankrupt
and when people freak out you go i'm
kidding
i'm kidding you didn't know i can't
believe you got you idiots
actually believe me when i said that how
stupid can you be
this is the kind of marketing um kind of
craziness that goes on you become
psychotic
when you're in this world long enough
that you kind of become a little crazy
to get to the top that's just what it
takes
so when i reflect on this video with
noah miller where he's talking about the
anamorph
i agree with so much of this which is
you kind of go a little nuts
when you're in this world but i think
it's not for the reason that like
money just makes you crazy in of itself
i think there's a lot of normal people
out there
with uh you know that are doing well off
this guy's probably one of them i think
he
makes a pretty good living but it's when
you're trying to market yourself as this
that you just constantly have to raise
the bar after all it's no surprise that
this is the
the climax of this guy's video he's
getting exactly what he wants dan pena i
mean he's getting uh
advertising sort of free advertising
because he's
crazy he's pitching himself as this like
crazy old man he's not really the
trillion dollar man but he calls himself
that
because he wants to be at the top so
that's how the game is played and
i think you know what i think this is a
workable scientific theory i don't know
what you guys think if we're gonna be
awarded for any kind of uh
nobel peace prize maybe the noel peace
prize or the
noble i don't know i think we should be
he should be i'm trying to ride the
coattails here but uh anyways let me
know what you guys think you agree with
this theory
do you not do you think the humble
millionaires are part of the problem
do you think that the flexing is part of
the problem let me know in the comments
below
thanks for watching guys see you in the
next
this ain't what it one nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee